[Musique]
bonjour à tous et à toutes
à l'occasion des élections municipales
ça aux cadis change de formule
bertrand carruggi mois nous recevrons en
alternance deux candidats par jour à
raison de cinq minutes par personne
nous avons évité ce matin georges joël
joseph merrill x bonjour bonjour
monsieur livry vous êtes candidat à
sainte-anne vous allez mener la liste
alternative synthèse vous êtes rédacteur
territorial à la ctm monsieur melix
pourquoi vous présentez je rappelle que
vous êtes aussi le président de l'aso
pamart alors pourquoi vous êtes
candidature pourquoi vous présentez à
sainte-anne bien tout d'abord je dis
bonjour à tous les martiniquais parce
qu'il ya matou toutes les 7 à l'aise et
toutes les 7 à l'est qui nous écoutent
et bien je suis ici devant vous chez un
ami cette année parce que vous le savez
je suis un enfant de la commune d'abobo
jeunes enfants de la commune
j'ai grandi à sainte anne au côté de ma
mère de ma grand-mère qui sont des
personnes bien connues à sainte anne
j'ai fréquenté l'école communale du bo
depuis mon jeune âge
j'habite cette année j'ai construit à
certaines donc je connais bien cette
année d'après moi et aussi la population
de cette année me coller pour mon
engagement depuis plus de 40 ans de la
vie associative particulièrement les
associations sportives telles que la
roue licence c'est un cap 110 et bien
sûr et plus d'une trentaine d'années
dans la vie politique
à sainte-anne être un train enfants de
la commune est ce que c'est suffisant
pour se présenter je suis merrill x
alors bien sûr que c'est pas suffisant
mais au regard de mon parcours et de mes
convictions
certains cette année m'ont contacté
depuis le mois de juin pour pour me
proposer de monter avec eux un groupe de
réflexion un groupe de travail avec
comme objectif la conquête de la mairie
alors l'association l'alternative c'est
un des ses couilles et j'ai été désigné
président puis candidat tête de liste
pour les élections
donc c'est tout pas coincé tout un
parcours qui fait effectivement que je
suis ici devant vous quels sont les
grands axes de votre programme monsieur
melix alors eux
puis au terme parce que effectivement c
est assez vaste un mépris autrement je
dirais que non mais l'accès ont mis
l'accent sur la fierté et cette année on
veut que les cette année on trouve la
fierté qu'ils avaient auparavant fierté
déjà au niveau de l'écologie parce que
c'est un jeu c'est une ville où pioneer
en matière d'écologie donc il faut que
certaines retrouve ses lettres de
noblesse en matière d'écologie
concernant la protection de
l'environnement pour nos générations et
les innovations futures et fierté
retrouvée au niveau de l'attractivité
parce que c'est à nous n'oublions pas
c'est une communes classées touristiques
depuis 2000 2012 donc c'est inadmissible
effectivement que l'image de c'est en
soi ou aussi dégrader et le taux de
fréquentation à cette année soit aussi
et puis subi une baisse vertigineuse
alors nous disons aussi que la fierté
sera retrouvé au niveau sportif pour une
commune comme c'est une petite commune
de cette année double champion et de
martinique de football avec la
renaissance double champion de
martinique de handball avec cet accent
10 et avec cette incapacité au triple
vainqueur de la coupe de martinique
triple vainqueur de la supercoupe bref
il faut qu'on retrouve ce niveau sportif
d'antan et tout ça aussi en matière
culturelle en matière culturelle en
matière de développement agricole pour
ses étés hocine s'est-elle de qualité
et donc l'agriculture la production en
élevage et adéquat je dois être un label
pour ses talents
monsieur mairie liste neil x est ce que
votre candidature ne porte pas le sceau
de la division du temps écolo
souverainiste tout simplement du camp
mal ça mais mais mais non je je dis que
non et il n'y a pas de division pour moi
c est tout simplement l'expression de la
démocratie monsieur niveau y est voilà
je viens quand même il y a quand même
monsieur pierre haïr qui lui est
candidat du modemas vous et il me semble
aussi aux modemas vous avez accompagné
un mal dans ses malles monsieur
livory pour vous répondre
et pour bien expliquer aux martiniquais
hausse est à l'aise qu'ils nous écoutent
je vais vous citer une petite citation
qui très ancienne cité assure une
citation bouddhiste qui dit que quand
l'élève est prêt le m apparaît donc
c'est exactement ça et de thil le cas
ici parce que l'homme dans sa quête de
connaissances ne doit jamais s'arrêter à
1 et structures ultime ne doit jamais
s'arrêter 1 anciennement ultime
il doit toujours travailler pour
s'améliorer avoir des connaissances
supplémentaires ce moment effectivement
cette étape mais ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas de la division là vous êtes en train
de me dire que non vous n'allez pas que
ce n'est pas de la division on en a pour
5 secondes même pas à peine seront onze
selebi l'ambition personnelle ce n'est
pas de la division ce n'est pas de la
division et vous virer sur le terrain et
vous verrez sur le terrain ce n'est pas
d'hier les visions je n'ai pas de la
division ni de la coupe de il n'y a pas
de collusion non plus je voulais c'était
monsieur merrill lynch je vous remercie
sa rocade est terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis
[Musique]